The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this is the last
but one lecture of the term.
So what I'm going to do
today is in about 45 minutes,
give you a quick history
of the internet from--
we'll start in the late
1950s and then get to today.
And then next time
on Monday, I'll
conclude this class by first
doing a wrap-up of 6.02,
and then also telling you
a little bit about where
I think the future of
communications systems
might be going I'll
probably be wrong about it,
but I'll be confident about it.
And today, the idea
is to try to connect
some of the topics we've
studied in the class so far
to this history.
Of course, we're not going
to be able to do all of it.
So the story so far in
terms of the history,
you have to assume--
so we're going to
start in 1959, or 1957.
And by this time, the history
of communication systems
has had a lot of successes.
And a common theme
is that there's
the technology that comes
around, it succeeds, it
tries to take over the world.
And right at the
time and it looks
like there's nothing else
that's going to happen,
some other new technology comes
around that over time kills it.
So the first successful
network technology
was the electric telegraph.
And the electric telegraph
was done by a number
of different people--
Wheatstone and Cooke built
an electric telegraph
in England, Morse and
Vail built one in the US.
The Morse code was developed as
part of the electric telegraph.
And that did a great
job in the 1830s,
1840s, 1850s, and so forth.
And then other
technologies came around.
Now, this sort of
story keeps repeating.
And so by the 1950s,
the dominant player
in the communication area
is the telephone network.
So we have the Bell Telephone
Company, and in the US,
it dominates.
There's equivalent telephone
companies in other countries.
And you have this massive,
amazing telephone network.
And increasingly, many
people have telephones.
On the wireless side, there
isn't a wireless telephone
system in the 1950s.
But what we have are radio--
broadcast radio and
broadcast television,
and some very powerful companies
that own wireless spectrum
to offer television and radio.
So the story starts
in the late 1950s.
And in 1957, a big
thing happened--
Sputnik launched.
And that caused the US to assume
that they were falling behind
in science and technology.
And that led to the creation
of ARPA, the Advanced Research
Projects Agency
that still exists.
It's known as DARPA today.
And it is probably the
biggest federal funder
of fundamental research and
a lot of applied research
and development.
Paul Baran in many ways
is one of the fathers,
or the father of packet
switch technologies.
He was working at a think
tank called the Rand
Corporation, which was
an organization that
really was a think tank.
It allowed people to think
about long-term fundamental
directions in
terms of technology
and where technology
was heading.
And he was looking
at the problem
of trying to build
what he called
a survivable
communication network.
And the story is
that he's trying
to build a network that
can continue to work
in the face of a nuclear war.
But that's really not what
he was trying to go after.
What he was trying to build
was just understanding
how do you design
communication networks that
allow you to handle failures?
And a lot of the then
telephone network
was a very centralized
kind of structure
where you would have a network
that had very little redundancy
built into it.
And you'd have lots of these
central star-like topologies.
And the problem, of course,
when you connect these stars
together, and these
star-like pieces connect
to other star-like pieces,
is that you had better
make these points here,
these nodes or switches
here, extremely,
extremely reliable,
and those links that
are connecting them
to these other
central structures.
Because otherwise, the
failure of those things
would kill the system.
And the Bell Telephone
Company actually
understood how to build
these very expensive, very,
very reliable switches, but
they were very, very, extremely
expensive.
The other problem is, and we'll
get back to this later today,
is that a telephone
network is a great network.
But it supports exactly
one application.
The application is you pick
up the phone and you talk.
It's very hard,
on the face of it,
to imagine how a
telephone network would
do a great job at supporting
the web, for example.
No one even thought of the web.
But even something
basic like being
able to watch a video
stream whose quality might
vary with time--
these are things
that the internet
did differently and did better
than the telephone network.
But the telephone
network fundamentally
had, in those days, a
fault tolerance issue.
And the way they
dealt with it was
to build extremely
reliable components.
Paul Baran's idea,
which other people
had been thinking
about and toying with,
was he observed that--
and in those days,
the telephone network
was largely analog.
The digital telephony
wasn't really there.
And digital computers were
just starting to come in.
And Paul Baran was probably
one of the first few people
who realized that computing
and digital technologies can
change life in terms of how
you build these systems.
Because the digital abstraction
allows you to know for sure
whether a component
is working or not.
Because if it works,
it gives you an answer
that then you can verify.
And if it doesn't work,
it just stops working.
It isn't like an analog
system where it may or may not
be working, and as the noise
increases or some fault occurs,
you're starting to
see a lot of noise.
And it's garbled,
you're not quite sure.
With a digital system, it
either works or it doesn't work.
You can build systems like that.
And he noticed
that you could now
start to think of building
reliable systems out
of lots of unreliable
individual components.
And this is the
fundamental guiding theme
for large-scale computing
systems from the late 1950s.
I mean, this goes
all the way to how
Google, or Amazon, or Facebook,
or any of these big data
centers work.
Any single one of
those computers
there is highly unreliable
relative to what
you could do if you
put in a lot of money
to build a very
reliable computer.
But the ensemble
is highly reliable.
And to do that requires a
lot of cleverness and care.
And the first real
example of this
is a digital communication
network built out
of this idea of packets.
In a couple of
papers that he wrote
in the late 1950s
and early 1960s,
he said that with
the digital computer,
you could now start to build
highly reliable communication
networks out of
unreliable components.
And so he articulated
this idea that you
can connect these
switches or nodes together
in highly redundant structures.
And if you have a
stream of data to send,
you don't have to really
pick a particular path
through the structure.
You could take that
message and break it up
into different pieces and ship
them in different directions.
And even if you chose to ship
them all in one direction,
if a failure occurred,
these switches
could themselves
start moving the data
in different directions, which
meant that you no longer think
of a communication
as a big stream
that you have to
send in one way,
but you can start thinking
about splitting it up
into these different pieces.
Now, like with many of these
ideas, it's rare to find--
sometimes it happens, but it's
rare to find exactly one person
in the world thinking about it.
No matter how
groundbreaking the idea,
there were other
people working on it.
And Donald Davies in
the UK in the early '60s
was looking at similar ideas.
And he actually coined
the term packet.
We use packets now to
mean these little messages
that you ship through
the network that
are atomic units of delivery.
This term was coined by
Donald Davies in the 1960s.
Now, all of this was
wonderful and sort
of theoretical abstractions.
But how do you start to
come up with some design
principles for building
communication networks?
In particular, how do
you deal with the problem
of having these links
come together at a switch,
and try to share
the links going out
of a switch in a way
that allows traffic
from different conversations
to multiplex on the same link?
The idea of having a queue
in a switch in retrospect
seems completely obvious.
But if you're the first
time you're seeing something
like this, and the
telephone network had
really no queues, the idea
that you would build a queue
and now start to analyze is a
pretty groundbreaking result.
Again, there were
many people involved.
But probably the
leading contributions
came from a person
called Len Kleinrock, who
was a PhD student at MIT.
And in his 1961 PhD
thesis, "Information Flow
in Large Communication
Nets," wrote
about how you could use queuing
theory to analyze and to model
communication networks.
Now, at around the
same time, again
at MIT, Licklider
and Clark wrote
a really interesting paper.
It's actually worth reading now.
I mean, it's 50 years
ago, but it's interesting.
You have to go back and
think, this was at a time
when people didn't really have
this idea that people could
sit in front of computers.
Computers were used
to maybe count votes.
I suspect they get
it wrong today more
than they did in those days.
But computers were
used to count votes,
they were used to help
with the US Census.
But nobody thought about people
sitting in front of computers.
And they wrote this wonderful
paper called "On-line Man
Computer Communication."
I guess in those days, you
know, man meant people.
So anyway, they
wrote this paper.
And in fact, Licklider
had this vision
of what he called a
galactic network that
would span the globe
and beyond, which was--
for the early '60s, it was
a pretty remarkable vision.
Now, using these
ideas, and particularly
Len Kleinrock's
ideas, and this idea
of man-computer
interactions-- which
of course, the idea of everybody
having their own computer
wasn't this paper's vision.
This paper's vision was there's
a lot of computers out there.
And people just had
remote terminals,
and you would log in and
have these big computers
that you could use.
But then you would
have nice interactions
on your own terminal.
That was what that
paper was about.
Larry Roberts was first at
MIT, and then moved to ARPA
to run this program, created
something called the ARPANET,
and wrote a paper
and wrote a program
that is a call for proposals
for the ARPANET, which
was a plan for timesharing
remote computers.
So the internet--
the ARPANET was
the precursor to the internet.
And it started not because we
wanted to build a communication
network to prevent--
for it to work when there
was nuclear war or any
of these major disasters.
It actually had a
very concrete goal--
just allow people-- computers
were really, really expensive--
just allow people, no
matter where they were,
to be able to harness the
power of expensive computing
far away, and make
it look to the extent
possible as if the
computers were with you.
That was the vision--
pretty compelling, but simple.
And they decided,
for very good reason,
to pick packet switching.
The reasons primarily
had to do with economics.
This was a network
that was being
proposed for an application
whose utility was questionable.
And the idea of investing
huge amounts of money
was not quite palatable.
And Larry Roberts
and others were very
taken by this vision
of packet switching.
So they said you know
what, the ARPANET is going
to be a packet switch network.
I'll come back to this
later, but of course,
the telephone
companies like AT&T
just thought this
was a terrible idea,
and were using every opportunity
to ridicule the idea.
The ARPANET was created, and a
few teams bid on the contract
for it.
And BBN-- Bolt,
Beranek, and Newman,
that's near Alewife
in Cambridge.
They're still there, they're
part of Raytheon now.
And they still continue to do
pretty interesting research.
They won the contract
to build this network,
build the technology
for this network.
And because the
processing involved
in the network, the
protocols that were involved
were considered
complicated, and considered
to be computationally
intensive, they
had to build a separate
piece of hardware
that they named the IMP, or the
Interface Message Processor.
And BBN won the
contract to do that.
The idea of an interface
message processor
is that every
computer, as well as
every switch, that
the switch would have
some hardware to forward stuff.
But you needed something
to do the computation
of both the routing tables as
well as actually every packet.
Every packet would
show up, and you
would have to compute some
sort of a checksum on it.
And you'd have to do this
computational task of figuring
out how to forward that packet.
And that was just
considered too much work
to have on an actual
little computer.
So they actually had to build
a separate piece of hardware
that you would attach
to your computer,
and it would probably
be about as big.
And you can see
the picture here.
These IMPs were attached to
bigger computers or computers
of the same size.
And these did the networking.
I mean, today, all of that
stuff, a million times more
is going on this device.
But back in the day,
that's how it was.
So they won this interface
message processor
contract called the IMP.
And when you win a
big federal contract,
oftentimes, your Congressman
or Senator writes to you.
In fact, it's funny
because a bunch of us got--
for a period of time before the
Senate election, a bunch of us
were getting emails, letters
from Scott Brown congratulating
us on winning some dinky
little NSF proposal.
I don't know if other
people here got it,
other faculty here got it.
But it's sort of like
in those days, if you
won a big contract,
you'd get money--
you'd get a letter
from your congressman.
So in fact, Ted Kennedy, who
was the senator at the time,
and was for many years,
congratulated the team
for winning this.
Except he got it wrong--
he congratulated them
on winning the contract to
build the interfaith message
processor.
I assume that if
they actually had
built that, it might have been
a more useful contribution
to world peace.
But all they managed
to get was the contract
to build the interface
message processor--
just details.
Anyway, so this team was
a pretty remarkable team.
They built the first--
they didn't build the
first email program.
That was done over
at MIT in the '60s.
But what they did do was
the first email program
that crossed different
organizations.
And in fact, the @ symbol
in your email addresses,
which of course, is sort
of the right symbol to use,
if you use the @ symbol.
But there was a person at
BBN, Ray Tomlinson, who said,
I'm going to put the @
symbol in email addresses.
And a lot of early
stuff happened
that continues to this day.
So they built this network.
And Kleinrock over at UCLA
was the principal investigator
on this--
now building systems out
of this piece of hardware
that was built. And this was the
picture of the ARPANET in 1969.
This became the internet.
There's a continuous evolution
from this four-node picture
to the internet today.
And in 1969, they finally
connected initially two,
and then four nodes.
And they had to do the
first demonstration.
And to listen to Len
Kleinrock tell the story,
this was his story.
He says that his group at UCLA
tried to log into a computer
at SRI, which is in Palo Alto.
And he said, we set up a
telephone connection between us
and the guys at SRI.
We typed the L, and we
asked on the phone--
because they had to check
whether it was working,
so they had the phone to check.
We asked on the phone,
do you see the L?
Yes, we see the L,
came the response.
We typed the O, and we
asked, do you see the O?
Yes, we see the O. And we typed
the G, and the system crashed.
But you know, they
got something working.
And of course, there's
a nice statement here.
You know, a lot of people
worry about performance
optimizations.
But the most important
optimization in a system
is going from not
working to working.
And the fact that something
worked is extremely important.
Very soon after, they
connected the East Coast--
a bunch of computers and
organizations on the East Coast
to the West Coast,
MIT among them.
So there was a team over
at BBN, and a lot of them
were from MIT.
So MIT, BBN, Harvard, and
Lincoln Labs on this side,
and MITRE got connected
over at Carnegie--
today, it's Carnegie
Mellon University,
I think it was called
Carnegie Tech at the time--
University of Illinois, and then
long lines across the country.
There was a group of
Utah and in California.
Now, what were these links?
Anyone want to guess-- these
links across the country,
or between Harvard and
MIT, or across over there,
do you think they actually
went and put in new cables
and laid these wires?
What do you think they were?
They were phone lines.
And so this idea shows
up over and over again.
The ARPANET was
essentially an overlay
built on top of the
telephone network.
And in fact, it was
a hostile overlay.
Because the telephone
network didn't really like--
I mean, at the
time, they thought
this was just an academic joke.
But over time, it became clear
that this underlying network
was being used on top to
do something different.
And so there is
an overlay network
that's built-- and overlays show
up again and again and again.
It's just that they're
not as hostile these days.
Another example of an
overlay is BitTorrent,
or any peer-to-peer
applications--
Skype, all of these things
are overlays that are
built on top of the internet.
And in fact, a lot of the
reason for their existence
is because the
internet doesn't quite
do the right thing in
terms of the right behavior
for certain applications.
So people say, let me go
build an overlay on top of it,
wherein you take
a path involving
multiple links on the
underlying network
and make it look like one link
in the higher level network.
And when you do that, you
get an overlay network.
So this single
link on the ARPANET
is actually many, many
links with many switches,
and who knows how expensive it
is underlying in the telephone
network?
But all you have to do is
to pay the telephone network
some amount of money and
make a call or whatever,
and you get to view
it as a single link.
And you can do the same
thing on the internet.
Now, this protocol the
routing protocol they used
was a distance-vector
routing protocol.
It wasn't actually even as
sophisticated as the one
we studied.
But it was a
distance-vector protocol.
And distance-vector was
the first routing protocol
ever used in a packet
switched network.
And it continued on the
ARPANET for many years.
They continued
running this protocol.
OK, moving on, we move
from basic packet networks
to this problem of
internetworking.
And that went through
a series of demos.
So one of them was they had
a big conference in 1972.
And they were demonstrating the
simple packet switched ARPANET.
And it worked really well
except when they demonstrated it
to a team from AT&T, and
it didn't work at all.
And in fact, there were news
articles that were written.
And some people wrote
this was a nice network,
some people wrote
it never worked.
And AT&T just thought,
ah, bunch of academics,
it's never really going to work.
They wrote a modified
email program.
And the US was not the only
place where work was going on.
In France, there was a
really good team building
a network called CYCLADES.
And Louis Pouzin was the
principal investigator
of that system.
I think that CYCLADES
doesn't get enough credit
because often, as it is with
these things, the winner
kind of--
ARPANET became the internet,
and so sort of everybody
forgot everything else.
But CYCLADES actually came up
with some pretty interesting,
groundbreaking ideas.
The idea of articulating
that this network is going
to be a best-effort
network with these packets
that they called
datagrams, which
is a word that continues
to be used to this day,
was in this French network.
They originated the
sliding window protocol.
It looks obvious, but it's not.
You can see there's
lots of subtleties
in how you build such
a protocol and how
you argue that it's correct.
The first sliding window
protocol was in CYCLADES.
And TCP, which today
is the world standard,
used a very, very similar idea.
And they also use
distance-vector routing.
And they also implemented,
for the first time,
a way to synchronize
time between computers.
And they had a number
of interesting ideas
in this network.
The work was not just being
done in the wide area.
In 1973, ethernet was
invented at Xerox PARC
by a team that included
Bob Metcalfe, who
was another alumnus from MIT.
That was inspired by this
Aloha protocol that we studied.
And ethernet was
essentially Aloha
with carrier-sense
multiple access,
very similar to
what we did study.
This idea of contention
windows is a new idea.
They actually used the
probability method.
Ethernet standard evolved
in the late '70s and '80s
to use the contention
window that we now know.
And that same contention
window idea and carrier-sense
is used in Wi-Fi.
So you can draw
this stream of ideas
through that continue
to exist to this day.
It's interesting that
ethernet today doesn't use
carrier-sense multiple access.
Because ethernet today is no
longer a slow speed network,
it's a very fast network.
It's not a shared bus,
it's point-to-point links.
But it's called
ethernet, and it doesn't
use the same MAC
protocol other than when
you have low-speed ethernet.
On the other hand, wireless
uses the idea from ethernet.
And in fact, a
lot of people call
802.11-- they used to
call it wireless ethernet.
And the ideas just got
moved to a different domain,
but it's the same ideas.
And in fact, a lot
of the early chipsets
that ran the MAC protocol
on 802.11 networks
essentially were the same
as the ethernet protocol.
They use the ethernet MAC.
They had that piece
of hardware, they
would buy it and build
the box around it.
So this idea of taking
older technology,
and applying it to a new
context, and then modifying it
is something that
works pretty well.
Because it means that you
can leverage something
that already exists and
start making changes to it.
And over time, it looks
completely different.
Now, the US
government and DARPA--
ARPA was funding the ARPANET.
But there were companies
and other research groups
in the mix here.
And in those days,
it was not very
clear what was going to win.
And everybody was doing
research on coming up
with different ways of
connecting networks together.
And Xerox had a
system called PUP.
I don't know what it stands for.
I think it stands for the PARC--
Xerox PARC, Palo
Alto Research Center,
PARC-something protocol.
I don't know what the U is.
And in a way, there were
many technical ideas
in the Xerox system
that actually
were arguably better
in technical terms
from the ARPANET and TCP/IP.
But it was proprietary, whereas
TCP/IP was completely open.
And open meant that you
didn't have to pay anyone,
you didn't have to get
someone's permission to do it.
The process by which
things were standardized
was far more open
and democratic.
And it won not
because it was better,
but because it was out
there and open and free.
There's a lot to be
said for that model.
Because for a
network to succeed,
you need to lower
the barrier of entry
so everybody can participate
and implement it.
And if you make network
protocols proprietary,
it usually ends up not
benefiting anybody.
So now, I think companies
have started to realize that.
So everybody
understands that you
want to make standards
open, and then
keep secret any particular
implementation strategy for how
you implement it.
So you might gain commercial
advantage from implementation,
but you gain no
commercial advantage
from keeping a protocol closed.
There are exceptions
to this rule.
Like, Skype is an
exception to this rule.
But who knows?
In 5 or 10 years, I
suspect that Skype is not
likely to remain dominant.
There are going to be other
things that will come about.
And some of them might be open.
In the mid-1970s, this idea
that you now really start
to connect many different
kinds of networks together,
networks that are being run
in different organizations,
took root.
And this was the
internetworking problem.
And this is the problem--
people were working on this
packet switch technologies.
And there were many different
kinds of packet switch networks
that showed up.
So there was the Aloha
network over in Hawaii.
There were people building
packet switched networks out
of ethernet.
At MIT and Cambridge
University, there
were people who were very
enamored of something
called Token Ring.
I don't know if Victor
was at MIT at the time,
or any of my colleagues
were, but people
were building these Token
Ring-based systems that
were technically pretty
superior in some respects
and interesting.
And so there were many
different kinds of networks
that people were building and
connecting their own campuses
internally.
And you had to communicate
between each other.
The trouble was, there was no
single protocol to do this.
So ethernet had--
back in the day,
when you bought an
ethernet technology
from say, Digital
Equipment or Xerox or one
of these companies, you
wouldn't just get ethernet.
You'd get the
ethernet MAC protocol.
Then you'd get some sort
of network communication,
network layer between the
different ethernet devices.
And you'd get
something called EFTP,
which was an internet
file transport protocol.
So you'd get
applications around it.
So imagine now, you're
buying a network thing.
And you don't get to run
your own applications,
you get a stack of everything.
And you get a box,
and you only get
to use whatever the
vendor gave you.
That was the state of
networking at that time.
And people recognized
this probably
wasn't a very good thing.
Because what you would like is
to have a network where people
can come up and invent
their own applications
and run their own
applications on it.
But you now needed
a way to communicate
between these
different networks.
So how do you do this?
So this was a huge
project that a lot
of different organizations
were involved in.
But a large part of the credit
is given to two people--
Vint Cerf and Bob
Kahn, who were in some
sense the lead people in getting
a community of other people
together in building the system.
And they articulated these
visions and these ideas.
So Kahn's rules of
interconnection are as follows.
He first said that each
network is independent
and must not change.
So the idea that you can
bring networks together
and communicate, if it required
every network to change,
that wasn't a palatable idea.
The second is that he agreed
with CYCLADES and said,
best-effort communication
is what we need.
Because we cannot assume that
every network will guarantee
delivery.
There are some networks that
may guarantee delivery in order,
but you can't mandate that.
And what they said was, we
will design this network
with these boxes that
we'll call gateways.
And these gateways
will translate
between different
network protocols.
And in a pretty
radical departure
from the Bell
Telephone network, they
said that there will be no
central global management
control.
There is no central
place where the operation
of this worldwide network
or countrywide network
is going to be managed.
So it's kind of a
simple idea-- you
have your own internal network.
This might be an ethernet, this
might be some sort of Aloha
network or what have you.
But you have these gateways
here that sit and translate
between these
different protocols.
And we know the stuff as--
we now know that what they did
was a pretty good decision,
which is they made it so
that these gateways will all
agree on one protocol.
And the protocol
they standardized--
they got it wrong initially,
but by the late '70s,
they figured out that that
protocol will be called
IP, or the internet protocol.
So a node is on the
internet if it implements
the internet
protocol, which means
it has a agreed-upon plan for
how the addressing of nodes
works, and it has a plan for
what happens when you forward
a packet.
You have a look-up
and a routing table
that looks up the IP address
and then decides on the link.
And that's all you
have to agree upon.
So to be on the internet,
all you have to do
is-- a network has to
support IP addressing,
and it has to agree that it
will send packets of at least
20 bytes in size, because that's
the length of the IP header.
There's very little
else that it has to do,
so much so that people
have written standards
on how you can send internet
protocol over, you know,
carrier pigeon.
And you can-- and in fact,
someone demonstrated something
like this, where they
had these things,
and these pigeons
were delivering
these scraps of paper, and
there was something looking it
up and sending it on.
So it doesn't take much
to be on the internet.
So Cerf and Kahn started
then designing the network.
And they wrote in
their original paper
that you needed to
identify the network you're
in, and within the network,
a host that you were in.
And they said the choice
of network identification
allows for up to 256
distinct networks.
Like, how many networks
do you possibly need?
How many organizations
can you possibly have?
And they wrote, you know,
famous last words-- this size
seems sufficient for
the foreseeable future.
The problem is they
were slightly wrong.
The foreseeable
future in their case
was probably less than 10 years,
and it may not have been more
than five or six years.
But you know, they
made a mistake.
But what was interesting was,
the next time the community got
to make a change
in that decision,
they still made a mistake.
They decided that 32-bit
packet IP addresses are enough.
And we've run out.
We literally ran out,
right now, of IP addresses.
So they had these gateways
that would translate,
and you would run the
internetworking protocol,
or IP.
So in the 1970s, this
idea of internetworking
was all the rage.
And in 1978, there was
a really good decision
made to split TCP from IP.
And a lot of that motivation was
from a group of people at MIT.
There's a paper here that
you'll study at length in 6.033.
It's one of these
papers that you'll
study two or three times,
because it'll keep coming back,
because these concepts
are pretty important.
It's called "End-to-End
Arguments in System Design"
by Saltzer, Reed, and Clark.
They have many
examples, but the gist
of the end-to-end arguments
is that if you have a system,
like let's say a
network, and you
want to be able to
design a network,
and you have to make a
decision of what features
do you put into the network?
The end-to-end arguments
say that you only
put in features in
the network that
are absolutely essential for
the working of the system.
Anything else that's not crucial
to the working of the system,
you leave to the endpoints.
So if you think about
reliability as a goal--
like, does the network
need to put in a mechanism
to guarantee the delivery of
packets, the answer is no.
The reason is is that
that property is required,
for example, if you're
delivering a file,
but not if you're delivering
a video stream or talking.
Because not every byte
needs to get there,
which means you don't
put that functionality
inside the network.
You leave the function
of achieving reliability
to the endpoints, because
not everybody needs it.
And the only
exception to the rule
that the only function you
put inside of the network
is functions that are absolutely
essential for the system
to work is if the
mechanism leads
to significant improvements
in performance.
So for example, if you run on a
network with a 20% packet loss
rate, it makes sense
to have some degree
of reliability and
retransmission built
on a network hub.
Like, that's what
Wi-Fi would do.
Because if you
didn't do it, you'd
have sometimes a 20% or
30% packet loss rate.
And that would make
everything not work.
But we don't try to
design our network
so that between the Wi-Fi
access point and your computer,
we produce perfectly
reliable transmission.
If you did that, it
would then mean that you
would have really long delays.
And you would be providing
that function for applications
that don't need it.
If I want an
application that I would
like to just send
the bytes through,
if it gets through, great,
if it doesn't, then I'll
do something else, that's
a bad network design.
Unfortunately, there
are real networks today
that don't obey this principle.
cellular networks are
sometimes problematic,
like Verizon or
AT&T or something.
You find there in real
data that there are
long delays in these networks.
Because between the cellular
base station and your phone,
they have decided to
provide something that
looks like highly reliable TCP.
It's kind of a bad
network design,
but that's how they
do it, some of them.
And so this is an old principle,
but it's sometimes not
followed, and
that's not so good.
Now, the reason why packet
switching and this TCP/IP split
won in the internet compared
to various other proposals that
were floating around
at the time is
that this architecture,
the internet architecture,
is good enough for everything,
but optimal for nothing.
There is really no
application for which
the design of the internet
network infrastructure
is optimal.
If you wanted to build a
network to support voice,
you'd go build a
telephone network.
You wouldn't build a network
that looks like this.
If you wanted to build a
network to distribute television
data to television streams
to a bunch of people,
you wouldn't build the internet.
If you wanted to
build a network that
wanted to support
Facebook and nothing else,
you probably wouldn't
build the internet.
But if you want a network that's
going to support all those
applications reasonably well,
including applications that you
cannot imagine today, this
design is a very good idea
because it's very minimalist.
There's almost nothing
that the network does.
It leaves everything
to the endpoint.
So I would say in fact that
the most useful lesson, which
you will apply over
and over again--
I mean, let's say you
go work at a company,
or work on some sort
of research project.
And at various stages
of the project,
there are endless discussions
on what you need to do--
whether it's worth doing
something or not doing.
And the most important
lesson that you can take away
in system design is that
when faced with a choice,
try to make a choice that's the
simplest possible choice that
gets the job done.
Because most likely, if
you get the application
wrong of whatever it
is you're building,
if it's simple and
minimalist, you
could probably pivot around
and use the same thing
for that other application.
So there's a famous
set of quotations here.
One should always architect
systems for flexibility
because you'll naturally
never-- almost never know
when your design-- everybody
has these use cases in mind.
But let's face it, when
you're at the early stages
of a project, nobody
actually knows.
And you'll almost
always get it wrong.
So it's important to architect
them for flexibility, not
for performance, not for
lots of functionality,
just for being flexible,
and the bare minimum
to get the job done based on
what you think is necessary.
And it usually means
doing that even if it
means sacrificing performance.
Like I said, the most
important improvement
in the system's performance
is getting it to work.
Everything else is secondary.
So there's a nice quote
here, I don't know if--
any French speakers or readers?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I know.
Just tell me in English.
[LAUGHTER]
Good enough, all right.
AUDIENCE: Seems that
perfection isn't
attained when there's nothing
to add, but there's nothing to--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's great.
Yeah, perfection is achieved
not when there's nothing more
to add, but there's
nothing left to take away.
And this is a really,
really good lesson.
I mean, you guys,
every one of you
is going to go into
the real world,
either at a startup
company or a big company
where you're defining
a new product,
or a research project, you
go to graduate school--
at the beginning, you won't
know the right answers.
You have some
vague ideas of what
it's useful for when
you design anything.
And it's really
important to understand
that you should do the bare
minimum to get it work.
And it's a really,
really good idea--
less is more.
I have a very simple
way to think of it.
I tell my students
this repeatedly-- when
in doubt, just leave it out.
If you're not sure if you
need it or not, don't do it.
There's enough stuff to do.
And that's probably the
most important lesson
from many of the classes,
at least on the system side
that you'll be learning.
Of course, it takes a lot
of good taste and insight
and intuition to figure out
what's really important.
I can't help you there.
OK, so by the 1980s, the
internet started to grow up.
And the way in which you
wanted to handle growth
was this simple
but brilliant idea
called topological addressing.
So I'm going to explain
what that means.
In the very early
days of the internet,
and including the simple small
networks that we studied,
every network node had
a network identifier--
an IP address or some sort
of a name for that node.
So in the way in
which we looked at it,
nodes would have names
like A, B, C, D, and E.
But in reality, A,
B, C, of course,
there are some set of
bits that communicated.
And in the old days
of the internet,
you would have a
two-phase identifier.
You'd have a sort of a network
identifier or an organization
identifier.
So MIT would have
a set of 8 bits,
and then you would have
a set of other bits here
that communicated within
MIT what that number meant.
So just abstractly,
these numbers
meant nothing in
the global internet.
This could just be
110111-something.
And then you would have another
sequence of something else.
That was the basic idea.
Now, in the networks
we studied so far,
we wouldn't even have this.
Every network node would
just have some name.
So what that meant is you could
have a network address that
was some set of bits.
I could have a
network address that
was some other set of bits.
And the switches in
the network, in order
to forward packets
to you or to me,
would have to have entries
in the routing tables that
were one-to-one with all
of the different nodes
that they wanted to
communicate with.
So you would have
a routing table
that would be
essentially one entry
for every host in the
network, which doesn't scale.
It's just too much information.
So topological
addressing is the idea
that per-node routing entries
don't scale very well.
So what you would like to
do is organize the network
hierarchically.
And it's sort of similar to the
way in which the postal system
works.
So in the 1980s, they
came up with a way
of doing it using three
kinds of addresses.
I'll call it class
A, B, and C address.
We don't use those
anymore, but let
me describe what this kind of
area-based addressing means.
So here's a very simple,
abstract view of this.
The internet used to adopt
this in some approximate way.
But this is the conceptual idea.
You design the
network into areas.
So MIT might be an area,
Stanford might be an area,
Berkeley might be
an area-- you know,
BBN, all these different
people are their own areas,
organizations.
Areas have numbers
that everybody knows.
So that's the first part, which
might be an area identifier.
And then this is a--
within the area, you might
have a host identifier, or more
generally, an
interface identifier.
What I mean by interface is
that really on the internet,
my computer doesn't
have an IP address.
If I'm connected to the
internet by the ethernet,
the ethernet has an IP address.
It gets an IP address
by virtue of connecting
to a switch upstream of it.
M Wi-Fi network
has an IP address.
If I use the Bluetooth, my
Bluetooth has an IP address.
In fact, in general,
sometimes, my computer
might have four
IP addresses-- one
if I'm connected on ethernet,
one on Bluetooth, one on Wi-Fi.
And if I have one of
those cellular modems,
if I tether through
my phone, every time I
do one of those things,
I get an IP address, OK?
So IP addresses on the internet
name the network interface.
So the way this area
routing idea works
is that within
these areas, there's
routing as usual and
forwarding as usual.
So all these nodes have--
you could recursively
build sub-areas.
But if you didn't,
each of these guys
would have an entry for all
of the other nodes here.
And within these areas, you
would have border routers.
And these border
routers would only
have entries for
the other areas.
So if you wanted to send
a packet from area 1
to area 4, what you would do
is you would send a packet
to one of your border routers.
And that border router
would have an entry
in its routing table
to get to area 4.
It wouldn't know anything about
the details inside area 4.
And so you have a nice hierarchy
where inside the network,
you only know how to get inside
your network and to the border.
The borders know
how to get inside,
and the borders know how
to get to other borders.
But the border of
one area doesn't
know how to get inside
any other network.
So you can see now, you can
recursively apply this idea
and start to scale
the routing system.
Now, on the internet, what
ended up happening was,
well, they had to apply
this area hierarchy.
And very soon, organizations
started saying,
well, I have a big area,
and I have a small area.
So how big do you
make this thing?
In the very old internet,
these were 8 bits long,
and these were the
rest of the address.
If you have 8 bits, you can
only have 256 organizations.
And although Kahn and Cerf
thought that was plenty enough,
that clearly wasn't the case.
So by this time, people were
starting to build equipment
with these 32-bit addresses.
And all this hardware was
out there, so what do you do?
So what they said
was, all right,
let's have three
classes of areas.
For the really big guys,
we'll have class A addresses.
Then for the medium
guys, we'll have
class B. And for the little
guys, we'll have class C.
What that meant is
that we're going
to have class A allows an
organization to have up to 2
to the 24 addresses.
Because class A is
identified by 8 bits.
So you get 24,
which is 32 minus 8.
So MIT was pretty smart.
They decided that
they would go and--
you know, they were up
there, they were doing
a lot of networking research.
So they said, we're
going to go get ourselves
one of these class A addresses
because we're a big university,
and we've got lots of computers.
And it was probably the
case that at the time,
MIT probably had more computers
than most other places.
So even to this day, they
maintain this address,
which was 18-dot-star,
where the star refers to--
well, technically,
star dot star dot star.
So all 2 to the 24 addresses
that start with the number 18,
or in binary terms,
whatever the 18 is--
000-- I'm going
to get this wrong,
but there's some
8-bit number for 18.
So anyway, they went
and got this done.
Now, nobody wanted the class
Cs because the classes were--
you could get 2
to the 8 addresses
because the class C was
defined as a 24 base.
So you have 24 bits to
define the organization.
So you could have 2 to the
24, or some large number
of organizations--
not quite 2 to the 24.
But you'd have some large
number of organizations,
but then you'd only get 256.
Now, the organization
doling out these numbers--
there's a particular
organization.
Actually, it was not even
an organization at the time.
It was like this--
Jon Postel at UCLA, one guy
was doling this stuff out,
and then it became
an organization.
Jon Postel is great.
I mean, he was really--
the social aspects of how he
managed this was remarkable.
So he didn't dole
these out randomly.
And nobody wanted this,
everybody wanted this.
I mean, everybody wanted
that, but they got this.
And this was 16 and 16.
So you'd get 2 to
the 16 addresses,
and you get your 16-bit
identifiers for these areas.
And over time, as
the internet grew,
the obvious thing happened.
Because the thing is this is
like the Goldilocks story,
right?
This is like, it's too
big, and this is too small.
This is just right.
And pretty soon, there were
2 to the 16 organizations
on the internet, and we ran out.
Literally, they ran out
of class B addresses.
And by this time,
by the early '90s,
they realized that this
rigid decomposition
into addresses in this form
was just not quite right.
Because what you
really wanted was
a system where you allowed--
I mean, this idea of
an organization ID
didn't make sense.
Like, what if I need
2 to the 12 addresses?
Today, you would
have to give me 2
to the 16, which is ridiculous.
So if I needed 2
to the 12, well,
how do you actually do that?
Well, I could get four 2 to the
8's, but if those 2 to the 8's
were not contiguous,
then those routers
in the middle of the
internet would not
be able to treat them as
one and have the same prefix
to define the entire network.
They would have to have four
different entries, defeating
the purpose of, in
fact, using this kind
of area-based routing.
So the whole thing
was kind of messed up.
So they actually got
wise to this problem.
And they came up with a
more sensible, sane way
to deal with this problem.
I'll talk about that
probably on Monday.
Now, in the meantime,
in the 1980s,
this growth was
happening pretty rapidly.
And they started
getting organized.
Vint Cerf, who was
by then at ARPA,
appointed Dave Clark, who was
a senior research scientist
and professor at MIT to
a position of internet's
chief architect.
And he was instrumental in
writing and bringing together
a lot of people in
organizing how people do
this kind of standardization.
So there was an organization
called the Internet Engineering
Task Force, or IETF.
That's the organization
that determines and sets
the standards for the protocols
that run on the internet.
In 1982, a really
important thing happened.
This idea of this community
with the internet architecture
community got a real boost when
the US Department of Defense
looked at various ways and
competing ways of designing
networks, and kind of remarkably
for a Department of Defense
decided to pick the open
standard rather than some
proprietary standard, rather
than some closed standard that
is potentially more secure,
though it really isn't.
Remarkably, they
said, we're going
to standardize our
entire systems on TCP/IP.
And the Defense Department--
I don't know if it's still
the case, it probably is.
But in those days, it
was a huge consumer
of information technology.
It still is, it's just that
other people consume it, too.
But in those days, it was
probably the dominant consumer
of information technology.
And they standardized on it,
and they awarded a contract
to the Berkeley
computer systems group
to build TCP/IP, which by
then had become standard.
And there were many
implementations,
but they said, take Unix and
go build the TCP/IP stack.
And Berkeley did a lot
of interesting things
with it including creating
the Sockets Layer.
They came out with
what today is known
as open source implementations
of the TCP stack.
In 1983, MIT created
Project Athena,
which was the world's
first campus-wide--
campus-area network system.
And they did a lot of work
on things like filesystems,
distributed file systems, and
the Kerberos authentication
scheme, and a lot of important
ideas from this network.
And they also ran
the TCP/IP stack.
They didn't run
anything proprietary.
In 1984, the domain name
system was introduced.
For those who
don't know it, when
you go type in
www.mit.edu, something
converts it to an IP address.
And then your network stack
communicates and sends
packets over TCP or UDP or
these protocols to that address.
How do you convert this?
Well, again, originally, this
was maintained in a file.
This file was called host.txt.
And believe it or not, the
way this file would work
was that every night, I think
in the middle of the night,
every computer on the
internet would go and download
this file from one computer
that was located somewhere
on the west coast.
Like, literally, you
would get a host.txt file.
And of course,
you could hack it.
You could do whatever you want.
And the assumption, of
course, was that no one was--
I was told that
in the early days,
every computer had a root
password which was empty,
or these computers at MIT had
a root password that was empty.
Everybody could log
in to any computer.
And everybody was
completely trusted,
which I think is sort
of not true anymore.
But you would download this
host.txt file every day.
And it started-- as the
internet grew really fast--
You know, the internet has
been growing by 80% to 90%
a year, not just in the past
few years, not just in the '90s.
You know, it's been growing at
80% to 90% a year since 1980.
So it's just on
this amazing tear.
And so anyway, this idea of
downloading a file every night
is just not a good idea.
So they created the
domain name system.
They had to create--
the NSF, which was the
National Science Foundation,
got into the act.
And they became the
first internet backbone.
And the backbone-- the idea is
that this is a backbone that
connects all of these
different networks together--
in particular, all of the
universities together.
So they also picked
TCP/IP as a standard.
And again, the
important lesson here
is they picked it as a
standard because it was open,
because It was very clear that
these implementations were
available, they
were free, everybody
could contribute to it, and
everybody could beat on it
and improve it, and there
was no proprietary technology
that was held.
So what I will do here
is I'm going to stop.
I'll pick it up at
this point on Monday,
talk about congestion
control, how to hijack routes,
and how to send spam
without being detected,
and then talk about the
future of networking
and communications.